but the hash and health smokers at the
West Kathmandu offers a first-class
service America's public enemy number
one
is drug abuse this will be a worldwide
offensive whether it's mountaineering or
marijuana trekking to Everest or
tripping on LSD getting as high as you
can has always been central to the
Nepal's worst experience this is the
story of an American president who tried
to nip communism in the bud by
destroying a Himalayan hippie shangri-la
but in stopping the smokers he sparked a
Maoist blowback
[Music]
towards the end of the 60s youth started
living their countries in sorts of
places which was removed exotic and
something like the shangri-la's that
could trigger their imagination and so
on so Kathmandu had become famous for
that is one reason for carpenter being
famous outside Nepal is that people
could be smoked Gaza freely in this
country
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
that hippie trail followed the footsteps
of the ancient Silk Road but instead of
trading textiles its travelers swapped
the post-war social conformity of the
Western world for dreams of
enlightenment in the East some were
fleeing the Vietnam War draft while
others came to find themselves for
whatever reason every year from 1965 to
1973 tens of thousands of young people
buster hitchhiked the overland route
from Istanbul to Kathmandu and the
terminus of the hippie trail was a
single bustling urban Lane called Joce
rechristened by its new inhabitants as
freak street
there's a flood of young people from the
West wearing all kinds of dresses very
picturesque very dramatic the field is
steel sector and they all went to toe
chain why because there were small shops
where they could buy Gaza and people
started setting of restaurants all
around
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
they brought books they've got the
possibility of opening contacts to the
world outside and they came with the
music Jimmy and his music Van Morrison's
music Bob Dylan was introduced by the
hippies this this became very famous in
government
why did the king allow the hippies to
come here I am still surprised the king
has restrictions on everything but they
allowed the hippies to come here he
allowed them to move freely small Gaza
until the pressure came from the
American government itself and they bend
the free sailing and smoking of
[Music]
America's public enemy number one in the
United States is drug abuse this will be
a worldwide offensive dealing with the
problems of sources of supply as well as
Americans who may be stationed abroad
wherever they are in the world
a number of young Americans have become
addicts as they serve abroad whether in
Vietnam or Europe or other places many
youths who resisted the compulsory
military service in these days they also
came here but after the Nepali
government finally put an end to the
free sailing and smoking of Gaza they
they destroyed the crops the police
dispersed so many Gaza farms so they
were very angry about that matter the
youth the hippies are very angry
they lived in large numbers and I was
very sad when Isis said goodbye to them
they were friends after all whether or
not these young men are tuned in they've
certainly dropped out of the society
they knew together they've quietly
rejected the practical Western world and
seemed not at all sure that they'll ever
want to return
the hippies weren't the only ones
angered by prohibition in western Nepal
far from the capital city of Kathmandu
hashish cultivation was the primary
source of income sellers and growers
were arrested private property with
marijuana growing on it was forfeited to
the state the destruction of the
marijuana crops pushed tens of thousands
of subsistence farmers to the brink of
starvation
[Music]
seeing political opportunity in economic
collapse a communist party exploited
local grievances and persuaded residents
that only a violent overthrow of the
government would solve their problems
Nixon's global war on drugs was fueling
the communist ideology he was trying to
contain and we will never surrender our
friends the communist aggression by the
just say no Reagan era drug prohibition
had opened new opportunities for
corruption that led all the way to
Nepal's royal family King Birendra
and I have each discovered a new friend
a blockbuster report by Nepalese
journalists padam Tecate implicated the
king's brothers in Nepal's booming
heroin trade the government immediately
shut down taka rotties newspaper then at
3 o'clock in the morning a bodyguard of
the royal family entered Taku rotties
home and aimed a gun 18 inches from his
head shot in the face Taku Rotti
survived the attack he lost an eye but
lived to expose the Royal Family's
involvement in black-market heroin this
is a quick escape from grave reality
today
Nepal remains a thriving hub for heroin
and hashish Namaskar Swaggart saccadic
roam claim wat with stories of drug
busts addiction and violence mainstays
of Nepal's television news coverage
by 2006 the Maoists controlled 80% of
the country the insurgency based in Roma
and rook 'im had grown into a national
political force that paralyzed the
nation with a series of national strikes
and armed resistance to the king after a
decade-long civil war that claimed
17,000 lives
Nepal's monarchy was abolished and the
Communists elected to power the Maoist
have surged ahead boss both the
mainstream Left Party the UML as well as
the Nepali Congress today
Nepal's political situation has calmed
down and freak street is looking a
little bit lonely
Katmandu x' hippie past is running high
on nostalgia and low on foot traffic the
erstwhile hippie haven is now a hangout
for hipsters artisanal coffee shops
outnumber head shops and the old Eden
hashish centre is just an ordinary
budget hotel nautical dekes agua
dopamine gaga despite a small political
movement to legalize hashish marijuana
is legal one day a year for religious
purposes only the rest of the time
tourists and locals take their chances
on the black market with its wild days
behind it freek Street is mostly dropped
the drug trade and reinvented itself as
a destination for mountain trekking the
memories of the past don't say that man
would've later
these days the real action is in Tamil a
short walk from freak Street Kathmandu's
thumping nightlife hotspot offers
visitors every kind of indulgence that
was available during freak Street's
heyday and many more that the hippies
couldn't have imagined on their wildest
trip and a recent retro hit is reviving
Kathmandu's hippy heritage the hippies
open to reasonable that was a woman that
brought the hill of the West and then
established a link through love and
respect they respected the culture they
loved the culture that's something that
today's world needs when the hippies
came other people came to know about
Nepal it was a kind of a became a
surrogate shangri-la
[Music]
[Applause]